Hey, John.
My name is not Hank.
Who the eff is Hank?
Well, to that I say, clean up your language,
young person.
Or old person.
Or middle person.
No, my name is Craig, AKA WheezyWaiter on
the intertubes.
That’s right, if you ever see me on a lazy
river riding in an intertube, call me WheezyWaiter.
A few years ago, I filled in for you, John,
and I did my best impression of you that I could.
It was well received.
Roger Ebert of the Chicago Sun Times said,
“Two thumbs up!” several times throughout
his career about other things.
Anyway, if any of you nerdfighters miss Hank
right now, I will do some things that Hank does.
Dancing.
You gotta do a lot of hip thrusts when you hip
dance like Hank.
He also sings rock music.
Rock music!
Yeah.
What else does he do?
Breathing.
Pooping, I’m assuming, and other stuff.
He also smiles when he talks, then he talks
like this sometimes when he’s trying to
get his words out.
You know what I’m talking about, John.
So, all bad impressions aside, right now we
are celebrating Pizzamas.
In honor of me trying to be like Hank, I’m
going to tell you about the science of pizza.
The term “pizza” first appeared in a Latin
text around the 10th century in southern Italy.
Here’s a reenactment: Let’s call it pizza!
I learned everything about my Italian accent
from Mario 64.
Let’s go!
The Latin text was found in the town of Gaeta,
Italy, and it stated that a person of a certain
property is to give the bishop of Gaeta twelve
pizzas every day.
So basically, you have to give 12 pizzas to
the bishop if you are at a certain high income
level, or upper crust, if you will.
I’m sorry.
I’m so sorry.
Also, I just realized I’m talking about
the history of pizza and not the science of pizza.
History’s more your thing, John. I'm sorry.
Here’s the science of pizza.
Let’s go!
That’s the last time I’ll do that.
Most basic pizzas have three things—well,
four if you count joy—five if you count
bloating when you eat too much—but the three
are: bread, sauce, cheese.
Why did I have to look at that?
I have had pizza before?
The bread is made of flour, water, and baker’s
yeast, which is actually a living, single-celled
fungus called saccharomyces cerevisiae.
Yeah, I said a big word. That means I got to the science.
Boom! Scienced! Moving on.
And, of course, a crucial element of Pizza
John is the Pizza John mustache.
So, here’s the history of the mustache.
The oldest portrait of a mustache is an Iranian
horseman from 300 AD—BC.
BC.
Not AD.
I couldn’t find the photo, but I imagine
it looked something like this.
By “horseman” I assume they meant “centaur.”
And by “photo” I assume they meant “sewn
to a pillow.”
That is all I have for you today.
I assume you learned nothing.
Thank you Hank and John for having me.
I love doing these.
Please have lots more kids.
I’ll see you sometime.